the day is Thursday January eighth and
the show is gamespot news the host first
watered us the setting the gamespot
offices in San Francisco California the
producer Josh Shaw sets the shot the
microphone is affixed the stories are
memorized the sideburns are mostly
symmetrical all that remains is to say
that one little word action today's
Thursday January eighth and you're
watching gamespot news a new mafia game
has long been rumored to be in
development and fans of the franchise
now have new reason to hope that an
announcement isn't far off rick pascal
own the voice actor who played mafia two
protagonists Vito Scaletta in response
to a fan who said make mafia three
replied might have some exciting news
very soon originally rumored to be in
production in 2012 then thought to be a
launch title for the new consoles mafia
3 has yet to be confirmed by 2k games
though I hear we might have some news on
it very soon valve has announced the
dates for the International which is a
super cool name they give to a dota 2
tournament in which the winners become
instant millionaires kicking off on
monday august 3rd and running through
august eighth the six day tournament
will feature 16 teams vying for the
championship these dates also happen to
overlap with those of gamescom a massive
industry and consumer event in cologne
germany so it's gonna be a pretty big
week for gaming news and i'm already
frightened did you know that no
playstation console has ever been
officially or legally sold in China
sounds really fake but it's true from
2002-2014 China had a ban on selling
foreign game consoles due to concerns at
video games could negatively impact the
physical and mental development of
children after the ban was lifted last
year microsoft released the xbox one on
sep tember 29th and the playstation 4
was scheduled to launch this weekend but
that launch has been cancelled due to
quote various factors big tastic a
source told Reuters that it was due to
prolonged negotiations with Chinese
authorities and no new release date has
been confirmed the finalists for the
main competition at the independent
games festival have been
so if you're looking for a list of cool
to tell games to play you've got it 80
days invisible ink outer wilds the Talos
principle metamorph a bet and this war
of mine earned finalist status for the
grand prize which will be awarded at the
IGF Awards on march forth during GDC
there are a variety of other prizes as
well with even more cool as hell
finalists listed in the full article on
gamespot com / news and finally Rockstar
confirmed today the GTA 5 for the PC is
indeed coming out on January 27th
despite whatever weird steam release
date nonsense having earlier in the week
just want to confirm that for you guys
before I head out that's all for the
news today I'll see you tomorrow when we
wrap up the show there will also be news
in it
[Music]